In short, when we render images to the screen.
A pixel layout dimensions may well not equal a pixel
in real device terms. And that relationship isn't a
fixed one either. Here, we have the same page on
two different devices. But even though the image is
approximately the same size on both devices, this image only
needs less than half the pixels of this image
to be rendered at one to one. Rendering an image
at one to one gives the best quality. But even
more important, you don't want to be pushing a lot more
bits down with the network than the device can use, and
you don't want to have poor image quality because you're not
pushing anywhere near enough high resolution imagery either. The best
way to think about this is that it's much like the
difference between standard definition tv and high definition tv. For most
of my life I watched standard definition tv, but now that
I watch most shows in HD, when a show
is broadcast in standard def, I defininately feel like
I'm living like an animal. You need to deliver
an HD experience when the user's device supports it.